señora llena bienvenida a france 24 y
quisiera preguntarle qué perspectivas
tenemos de una vacuna se podría aspirar
por ejemplo a que la oms se apruebe la
distribución de la cura rusa
buenos días muchas gracias angela estar
con ustedes la organización mundial de
la salud viene trabajando desde
comienzos de este año para poder
acelerar el desarrollo y la producción
de las vacunas en este momento tenemos
más de 175 vacunas experimentales en
alguna fase de desarrollo ya hay 33
vacunas que se están ensayando en
humanos y eso es un mito en salud
pública porque desde que fue descrito la
secuencia genómica del virus el 11 de
enero han pasado 8 entre 8 a 10 semanas
para comenzar estos ensayos clínicos en
humanos y eso realmente es un hito muy
muy importante bueno teniendo en cuenta
de eso usted considera que es factible
que si a mediados de 2021 pueda iniciar
una vacunación pero más aún si esa meta
se cumpliera cuando podríamos aspirar a
tener las vacunas en américa latina'
hay un esfuerzo muy grande como les digo
de la organización mundial de la salud y
con varios socios estratégicos y a
través del mecanismo mundial
kóvacs que está trabajando también la
organización panamericana de la salud
con ellos a través del fondo rotatorio
para la compra de vacunas se está
buscando a acelerar este proceso de
desarrollo y producción si la
organización mundial de la salud lo ha
anunciado que para el segundo entre el
segundo y tercer trimestre del próximo
año podríamos tener ya la vacuna a nivel
de los países en el bloque de países de
latinoamérica y suramérica en la región
han confirmado este interés de poder
adquirir la vacuna a través del
mecanismo kóvacs y en nuestra región
tenemos el fondo rotatorio que viene
trabajando por más de 40 años en la
adquisición de vacunas para los países
de la región y eso nos da una una
certeza de que podamos tener a nivel de
todos los países esta vacuna
el próximo año